sur la rive asiatique d'Istanbul ce café
est devenu un point de rendez-vous pour
celles et ceux qui ont fui la Russie
nous y rencontrerons Sergueï brièvement
détenu après une manifestation contre la
guerre en Russie il avait déjà gagné
Istanbul au printemps dernier avant de
rentrer à Saint-Pétersbourg puis de
revenir précipitamment il y a quelques
jours
je ne connais personne désormais qui
pense calmement que la guerre ne viendra
pas chez eux
parce qu'en fait ça y est elle est déjà
là
être forcé de tuer les gens que je n'ai
pas envie de tuer des gens qui
je ne serai pas d'accord
et ça veut dire que je devrais aller en
prison
accélération des procédures pour obtenir
un titre de séjour ou ouvrir un compte
en banque les autorités turques ont
mises en place des dispositions pour
faciliter l'accueil des Russes mais
elles ont dû faire marche arrière sur un
dossier en particulier
désormais les 5 banques turques y
compris trois publics qui acceptaient
les cartes de paiement russe Mir pour
décider de suspendre leurs opérations
avec le système à la suite de pression
de Washington qui voyait un moyen de
contourner les sanctions économiques
imposées à Moscou depuis février les
services Turcs ont enregistrés près de
50000 demandes de résidence russe
certains sont partis d'autres sont
restés comme Nico qui travaillent pour
un célèbre réseau social
je ne pouvais plus travailler en Russie
parce que Facebook a été déclaré
organisation extrémiste donc je risquais
un emprisonnement de 3 à 8 ans si je ne
me trompe pas
il y a quelques jours cette lettre est
parvenue à son ancien adresse en Russie
qu'est-ce qui est écrit
et ça dit que conformément à la Loire
russe je dois me rendre au commissariat
militaire pour vérification
d'informations
plus d'une centaine de vols relient la
Russie à la Turquie les avions sont
pleins les prix multipliés par 10